the Downs family admit they found home
teaching enlightening but difficult the
parents want their boys to go back to
school but they aren't convinced they'll
be safe from coronavirus yet under the
government plan the younger boy
Sebastian would be first back when you
send it back I would be very reluctant
I'll have to be honest it would concern
me a lot I personally think too much is
happening so quickly even those parents
who agree with school's reopening were
waiting for more details from the
government we're asking schools to adopt
a number of strict protective measures
this includes reducing class sizes
making sure pupils stay within these
small groups creating a protective and
small bubble around them school staff
can already be tested for the raipur
virus but from the 1st of June we'll
extend that to cover children and their
families we owe it to the children the
globe primary academy in lansing west
sussex is one of the many schools whose
trust is backing the government's
reopening plan in fact the globe has
never shut since lockdown it's been
teaching 30 or so children of key
workers and others the school's parents
are divided my children won't be going
back because I don't feel that the
numbers are low enough that it's safe
enough for them I will mind to go back
just for their mental health being being
with their friends normal routine social
distancing and the young children's
ability to observe it is a major concern
the UK has the largest primary school
classrooms in the developed world
according to the Organisation for
Economic Cooperation and Development in
all of this decision about reopening
schools are the risks obviously around
health and safety but also of the issues
around the benefits to children of being
in school and in particular there is a
sir disadvantaged children being outside
of school primary schools in France
opened earlier this week
teachers were masked and pupils kept
apart however odd that must have felt in
Denmark young children have been back in
school for a month
similar precautions but no masks in a
country that locked down early in the UK
more than one council is refusing to
reopen schools on the 1st of June in
Hartlepool the and the wider North East
our rate of infection is double of that
in London so whilst it might be
appropriate to open schools in various
places right now in the Northeast we
don't feel like I saw in the face of the
push to reopen teachers do have the
legal right to stay away from school if
they feel unsafe as things stand they
have the backing of their own unions and
the doctors union the British Medical
Association who all feel it's too early
whenever schools reopen hygiene is
likely to be high on the curriculum
Martin brunt Sky News West Sussex